in in light of this conversation about
our rights
with everything that's been happening
where do you
let's talk about the split
what what do you think is uh uh you're
optimistic you said that you think we're
going to have a resurgence and some
patriotism a new president who comes and
saves the day or do you think it's all
going to just crumble fall apart look i
i have to think that somehow we're going
to get through this and where there's
going to be a new day where we realize
that it's important uh to respect our
rights to create a civil society where
everybody can participate
and uh
where it's not run for the pure benefit
of an elite upper class there will
always be an elite but we used to have
an elite that at least pretended
to to to care about the nature of the
country and the people in it we don't
have that right now
um the split is my sixth uh uh kelly
turnbull action novel people run around
shoot people that this story is america
has split into into red and blue areas
the hero goes into the blue areas to do
missions and sees how things are
happening the split takes place about a
year six months a year after the country
has split in two so this is like your
imagination of what would happen if this
really did happen right yes basically
yeah so how does the country split uh
country uh basically comes up to the
brink of war
and negotiates uh uh a
somewhat peaceful
uh split into basically but what's the
underlying
fracture is it just tribalism it's
exactly what we're seeing now it's an
elite that uh wants to oppress it is uh
normal americans who don't want to be
oppressed uh there is some violence some
red states like you know abbott de santa
say we're not going to comply exactly
some of the some of the bigger uh red
states refused to comply there was a
crisis which was the book that preceded
this crisis
and that covers
the the split up of america in my my
timeline
and uh all through it you know you have
my little action hero running around
this wilson combat cqb 45 shooting
liberals and seeing people uh be wacky
and he's dealing with a lot of these
folks and america blue america is
essentially a a giant college campus
people's talking about their pronouns
you know sports team uh you know forced
to uh you know invite fat athletes so
that their
anti-fatism uh it's almost what's that
what's that um
i can't remember the idiocracy no no no
i mean yeah the short story about how um
harrison bergeron yes yes yes yes i know
it's just like right there uh kurt
vonnegut uh
uh uh another kurt who writes let's so
does this does this follow the timeline
properly with the other story you had uh
yeah well look i've written the books
out of chronological order i actually
conveniently have a list in fact
i've got like 425 reviews in amazon most
of them five star which i'm super
appreciative of people love these books
and i i really enjoy writing them and i
hope i'm saying something but that in
these reviews a startling number are
like and in his preface which you should
read kurt lists the timeline of the
books because they're i didn't write
them chronologically in the timeline uh
so you can write read them as he wrote
them you can read them in chronological
order to see how things go
uh but it's uh you know i'm now on six
books so i've kind of got like a cannon
and i feel like those star trek guys you
know and people are coming up going you
know your character kelly turnbull in
number one he said his social security
number was one two three four five six
seven eight nine
but
in the new one it's one two three four
five seven nine
what's up with that
it's like would you typo would you
advise them really chronologically or
from the beginning but let's go let's
talk about the story um
you don't you don't think it's going to
happen though no i i i think we're going
to figure look i i think we're going to
have uh in 2022 2024
a uh
a a backlash and i think we're going to
muddle through that doesn't mean we will
that means i think that's the most
likely result and frankly it's the one i
hope for what do you think the
democratic establishment will do when
they lose control of the house but
retain control of cultural institutions
um and the presidency well
if we have a
well
are they up there they're up to lose the
senate as well right yeah they could
lose the senate it's less likely they're
almost starting to lose the house just
on structural factors
gerrymandering uh which we should do
ruthlessly because they're going to i
want to pause real quick and explain how
important and good gerrymandering oh yes
the people who claim that gerrymandering
is bad these people are authoritarians
who are trying to lie to you and
manipulate you you see the memes all the
time where they're like gerrymandering
is bad and here's why and they show
three squares and within each square you
can see 40 red and 60 blue and they say
in each of these districts a democrat
will win now let's do gerrymandering and
then they shape the inside of the cubes
in certain ways so that it's only it's
like
it's like three to two red and
republicans win and then they always say
see that's why it's bad they will they
will then show you a map and on the map
you'll see like dan crenshaw's
district for instance it's like a weird
moon shape with like weird lines
connecting it and they're like see it
makes no sense right
what should it look like a square but
what about industrial centers what about
factories are those gonna fall inside
his congressional district no
they draw these things to make sense for
two two very important reasons one
when it's drawn all weird it's because
that's where people live yes and they
think it's gonna be a square it's like
that's a that's a sea world dude
he's got he's got he's got it's got to
be over the houses so they connect the
residential areas and it looks weird the
other reason is if we just did it block
by block you very well could end up with
zero representation for a strong
minority who then says i object because
they're no longer getting listened to
exactly uh
ideally representatives districts should
be representative
uh but they don't have to be perfect and
uh you know the the
party and power in each state has the
ability to draw lines to its advantage
to get one or two extra seats uh in new
york
i think there are right now eight
republicans they're probably going to
cut it down to three yeah and i think uh
and and in ohio
there's a map you could draw a legit map
that and there's some voting rights act
stuff to make sure that minority
communities have represent
representation
that's just a fact i'm not arguing for
against it uh but you could uh you could
get a 13-2
uh republican ohio if you did it uh
certainly and i say you should do it
because everybody's gonna do it so back
to the back to the main issue uh
republicans control a majority of the
states state houses which means they can
draw up the congressional maps yes which
means republicans just on that factor
alone are poised to win at least what
does eleven seats need to be yeah well
they need five to win five to take over
and what do you think is going to happen
when in 2022 the democrats lose the
house they've already been tweeting if
we lose the house it's all over i wonder
what they mean by it's all what is that
reference to and then what happens in
2024 when
trump or desantis wins
we already saw how insane they got in
the first term of trump do we do are we
just going to assume that they're going
to sit back look look what uh uh it was
reported by the boston globe what's um
what's the guy he did the hillary
campaign i can't remember his name
vanessa john podesta yeah look what he
said uh during
boston globe said that he he advised the
west coast to secede if donald trump
were to win the election
so what's going to happen come 2024 they
lose cultural power 2020 they lose house
power in 2022 we then start seeing
well i don't want to get optimistic but
maybe republicans will use subpoena
power i really doubt it well look i i
if we get a republican in there who is
woke who knows what time it is which
which
you mean red build
red pilled yeah woke is the other way
i like woke welcome focus my word i'm
taking woke back i'm with you i i want
woke i man i'm insomniac woke i refuse
to sleep no ambien for kurt
um
i want a republican let's let's call it
ron desantis because donald trump is not
that guy donald trump still believes in
institutions which is adorable
but
you know
i i i and i'll support him if he's the
nominee uh but uh
you know he's gonna have primary i think
i don't think he walks in by any means
i uh nor should he i am unsentimental
about politicians you've got to prove
you're the best you got to prove you're
the winner and there's no gimmies and uh
no favorites
battle royale thunderdome first do you
think republicans should that one
interesting thing is we have a ton of
republicans running now like the
announcements are apparently like huge
numbers of people getting active and
getting involved yeah a lot of them are
i mean like
mike pompeo's a nice guy but i don't
know
oh for the house the house is great
great it's it's crazy oh we're seeing
some candidates in some areas oh my gosh
people are
people are super motivated and that's
great because that starts building our
bench
and then you have people like scott
pressler who's doing voter registration
love scott and he's saying
republicans right they're going to
overtake democrats and voter
registration so these are really good
signs yeah and uh
do you think the republicans will use
the powers of the house at all the way
the democrats did um
kevin mccarthy is going to have to walk
a fine line between the old republicans
and the new ones
and uh and and he could resign he won't
uh but look i mean look
we're adults here there are factions our
faction is not the majority our faction
is the best we are indisputably correct
about our general principles
but not everyone agrees with us we gotta
convert some we got to win
uh electoral fights against others and
we've got to use pressure and if kevin
uh kevin mccarthy feels the pressure to
conform the way nancy pelosi has felt
pressure from her radicals which is a
squad and i guess i'm calling ourselves
the radicals if only because we are not
the establishment
uh that's okay
i don't care why they conform as long as
they can form
and then come 2024
will the democrats go insane they will
desantis wins they will
but we need somebody who is conservative
woke who understands that every
institution is dominated by the left and
wants to uh bulldoze at all i mean
destroy academia i mean end student
loans no more grants to them i mean
impose uh uh you know you know where hey
guess what
free speech on campus if you don't
defend it you're in trouble you know we
need we need a great reset of academia
oh yes the idea that we're we're having
young people take out hundreds of
thousands of thousands of debt disgrace
to go to a building to read the internet
yeah exactly
exactly and look i uh you know i i've
got teenagers uh so i kind of hear some
of what teenagers do like i'm 56 years
old okay my my finger's not on the pulse
and i don't get their music
uh at all
but uh a lot of them are unbelievably
woke about the college scam they're like
i'm not gonna go to i'm not gonna go to
some giant college get a useless
credential that's not gonna help me walk
out with this anchor around my neck
uh you know i'd love to hear it i
you know there are other things i can do
maybe i go out there maybe i'll start a
podcast which i think is beautiful
there's so god there's so much
opportunity out there we just need to be
unleashed there's so many ways people
can create a life that they want to you
did it
you've done it you've done it i've done
it we built lives we wanted to live
think about that that is unprecedented
in human history how many people got to
say it muslims spent their whole life
you know
rowing a
is that we've we've taught too many
people to to be envious
and so what you get is
people who desperately want to fit in
yeah by just doing what they're told to
do yes and that's how you end up with
people believing the economy is good
yeah media says it i'll believe whatever
they say so i can fit in that's how you
succeed instead of realizing that doing
what you want to do and just doing it
good
well is what brings success exactly and
then look education may be part of it
look i i needed a law degree to be a
lawyer and a strategic strategy degree
to be a colonel that's fine i got those
they didn't stop me from doing other
things
i i but
you know the the
i was talking to the guys downstairs
about being at uc san diego and i
remember literally two things i remember
a little bit about the uh uh from
classes
all right
i i had been i worked on capitol hill as
an intern through the college i wrote on
the comedy paper in the political paper
uh you know i drank a lot of coors i saw
the jesus and mary chain live i mean i
did a lot of fun things but from classes
i learned a little about uh uh
containment in the cold war and got to
talk to michael malus about by the way
that's his next book
and uh i i learned about proportional
voting in one particular class and i
understand it and i don't like it but um
that's literally all i got from the
classes
i could have not ever gone to a class
and i'd be the same person yep and
that's i mean you know my favorite thing
is
when people on twitter are like tim
pool's a high school dropout and it
shows and i'm like bro you have like
you're just like some random anonymous
guy on twitter and like i'm running a
big multimedia business dude
wake up dude go work go work for
yourself stop thinking about other
people this is what i'm saying
they spend so much time caring about
other people instead of themselves well
look i i mean
high school dropout what does that mean
you means i found institutionalized
learning facilities to be a waste of
time yes
and you're here you you just had a guy
with two advanced degrees
a law firm
uh who was a colonel in the army and i
jumped on a plane to fly across the
country to sit here talking to you for
two hours
that seems pretty freaking good to me
hard work pays off thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you